what the [ __ ] is up with that you think
I look like a damn tiger King extra hi
I'm Tom Segura and I'm going undercover
on the Internet
it's actually me seriously it's actually
me
first up Instagram my head gets loud
rights damn really you and Bert
Kreischer dropping dis close to each
other
what is this the end of the world
usually I read that type of comment with
a chuckle but if you're not aware it is
quite accurate at the moment so yes the
world is ending all right next up
something clever on Instagram rights did
you have your eyebrows done for this
damn it no I did not but yes the makeup
artists went crazy on my face thanks for
reminding me posted
next Erin cougar melon ball myrrh okay
but why is your shirt still on oh this
is in reference to my friend burnt who
doesn't wear clothing during his
specials I have a different approach it
involves you know the joke-telling next
Rob is Lord rites
is this a Mary Kay ad oh haha you rob
next June
Kuya rights is that an Ewok no it is a
photo of my adorable dog bitsy
she is a Brussels Griffon and she does
look like an Ewok but I just want to set
the record straight that she is a proud
Brussels boom Twitter why the F does Tom
Segura have a better thigh gap than me
in ball hog well that is an interesting
question and they are called front
squats
moving on Tom Segura is new special
great but like how much time did it take
for him to perfectly line up the bottom
of his shirt
with his jacket and keep it that way for
the whole special
did he use glue please explain no I did
not but I do credit Seth Chernoff
stylist wardrobe extraordinaire II made
it so that those things fit perfectly by
taking them to a tailor you know a
tailor hems your pants they'll do it to
his shirt too next up
nice twits wrote hey Tom how high should
I get before I watch ball hog
I would suggest getting extraordinarily
high the first viewing and then watch it
sober and then compare how you feel with
each of those experiences next sage
Brown writes which Ferrari does the
water champ drive now sadly sage I don't
have a Ferrari hmm hope I get a few more
specials though and then I can get one
next Haru
who's handle is TISCO knee rights I'm
thinking about shaving my head because
I'm balding and wanted to know how often
you have to trim to keep it manageable
also will I have to apply foundation up
onto my scalp or should I just stop at
the top of my forehead like usual it
really starts to grow quickly once you
trim it down so I would buzz your head
once a week and apply foundation however
you choose there are no rules anymore
next Vasudha Andy writes in all caps Tom
Segura has a podcast in Spanish
si hombre si quieres metal enemas in
Internet
mooska Tom Segura espanol puede sacar
dos semanas de semanas a assemble some
focus in Spaniel that's it for Twitter
YouTube next we go to YouTube YouTube on
the sketch or the video my mom hates my
comedy sketch silky Johnson writes was
that top dog in the background
little-known fact
when the Marines landed in Da Nang they
only sent one man and top dog and he
would love that that was him in the
background that is my father retired
Marine Corps captain thomas and segura
and he is one bad mother-- top dog is my
dad he is a proud marine sometimes I'll
say oh you know you're a former Marine
and he goes there's no such thing as a
former Marine you're a marine I love my
dad very much and he loves the Marines
for sure looks like we have a comment
here from Joe Rogan experience episode
1447 the comment is Tom looks like he
came from the tiger King special that is
super insulting I understand what some
of these Oklahoma Hillbillies look like
because I watched it too and I don't
look anything like that you what the
[ __ ] is up with that you think I look
like a damn tiger King extra this is a
comment left on episode 22 of two bears
one cave this is good psycho not
commented will someone tell me why
people in LA are always wearing hoodies
sorry I'm a POS from Nebraska thanks I
don't know if you know this hoodies are
quite comfortable also we are in a
studio that is often 60 degrees how can
you have anything against hoodies
honestly I don't know why you're opposed
to them but you need to rethink
everything in your life right now
replied all right this is on the Tom
Segura ball hog trailer on Netflix cubm
rights why
does everyone care so much about his
lips it is a great question there was
something that happened I did get too
much makeup and they released a trailer
Netflix did that was color corrected
incorrectly so I looked like I was a
Geisha with like really white face and
red lips and then they took it down and
they recolored it people know about that
they've been making comments about lips
and etc etc well sir you are a decent
person because there is no reason to
comment about the lips because they were
fixed and all those people are dicks
there you go now we go to IMDB so our
IMDB and it says personal details five
eleven and a half I take real issue with
this as far as I know I am 511 and 8/10
I like to round up somebody says how how
tall are you I'm going for an even six
if you have a problem with that you know
I have a problem with you read on reddit
did anyone else see Tom at the overwatch
to reveal I got to tell you something as
far as I'm concerned with my eyes right
now that is me I had a great time at the
overwatch to reveal pora how does Tom
Segura make money Tom makes money doing
stand-up and podcasts and writing and
sometimes acting though not as often as
he should from acting is Tom Segura
funny that is entirely up to you what is
Tom Segura's best stand-up special
they're all unbelievable it's hard to
answer this because they're so
overwhelmingly great but my favorite is
the most recent ball hog that's it I'm
signing off the internet now I'm Tom
Segura and that was actually me